So hello, thank you for being here especially so early
I know it's early in the morning and I appreciate you coming waking up and coming to this weird talk had a Python conference
so emotional intelligence for engineers
So, oh, no just the elephant in the room. This is a Python conference. So who's this lady?
And why is she here to talk to us about our feelings?
well, I'm glad you asked so I
Hypothetically, so my name is April Wenzel, and I'm a software engineer and I have been for the past decade
I worked in a number of different
Startups in Silicon Valley and I've led engineering teams including some using Python for some interesting stuff in machine learning to detect autism the kids
Do other things with Python pigs and Python and as far as why I'm here
So every talk at this conference is really about how to become a more effective developer
And I think that this talk is no different because I truly believe that emotional intelligence
It's key to becoming the most effective developer that you can be
Also, I know that the Python community is a big fan of inclusion, especially in recent years
And so emotional intelligence is key to creating inclusive environments
So learn more about me I come from San Diego. I took this picture the day before I left
It's all this water coming from the sky. Is there any foreign to me, but I'm trying to make do other than that
I'm very much enjoying your city
So I just tried to slice the sunflower cafe a recommendation from Justin Hoover and it was delicious. This is all vegan
It's a barbecue sandwich and you can see the casserole. Just amazing. So very very happy to be here in your city
Ok, so I want to go over the plan for this talk
I'm gonna talk about what emotional intelligence is why you should care about it
I'm gonna focus a lot of time on that cuz I think it's important and how you develop it
So my company is called compassionate coding and I do workshops on emotional intelligence for engineers
But before all that I used to be kind of jerk
I have detailed my jerk days in this blog post
Which has actually gotten some attention online
Including some attention on reddit where people are not always the most emotionally intelligent in their communication
So I got some interesting jerky comments autopost about being a jerk
But that's okay because that none of them are his jerky is leaves that I am to myself
so, but anyway in this post I talk about how I used to be very
Focused on just the technical side
I thought okay if I'm perfectly
Logical and rational because of course I am right and programmer then I don't have to worry about other people's emotions. That's their problem
They're offended by what I say. That's their problem. I also you know, so I was so totally focused on that
I have very not emotionally intelligent
actively anti emotionally intelligent
so I've mentioned this because to all the any of the negative nancies or Nettie's in the audience who are thinking
This is a stupid soft talk
I assume there probably aren't that many of you because you chose to be here, but if you came just to heckle I
Encourage it, but let's save it to the end. So that bless distracting for everyone else
but yes, so if you are feeling that skeptical I
Understand I have deep empathy for you because I also would have made fun of this talk and thought it was silly
so please bear with me so the one exception to the not heckling is
I'm trying to avoid using guys for mixed gender groups. So
This I would say this is not a picture of guys. This photo comes from this great site
Women in women of color and type attack calm we can access stuff that is done at women in color tech
I would also say that this is not a group of there is
Also, not a group of ladies
So I'm gonna try to use these terms folks everybody everyone people all in because in the south and from Texas y'all
friends a team
so if you hear me say
guys when I'm referring to a mixed gender group or a group of unknown gender then just raise your hand and
Because I want to get better. So thank you for helping me out with that
So those feel intelligence what is it?
I'd like to talk about what it's not
So it's not just being fake. It's not just being nice. It is not ignoring logic and reason
This is I thought this is a really cool picture. It supposed to be a Rubik's Cube then destroy itself
We're not destroying or forgetting logic and reason it's not sugar coating
So this is what I used to think it was
And that's why I hated it so much because I was like we should just be too to each other
We shouldn't be sugarcoating and it turns out it's not sugarcoating. So steady clear
It's not that it also doesn't mean being an extrovert or a social butterfly
I get that sometimes where people think well, I'm an introvert. I'm an introvert
Okay, and I am definitely by no means a social butterfly and I still think you're able to build emotional intelligence
So it's not that
It's also not being completely ruled and dominated by, you know, your emotions your unbridled and bridled emotions. I
Posted about giving this talk on LinkedIn and some honked and also gets get some interesting trolls
but somebody comments it and they're like
you know ya motions are great and all but we don't want to be
But it's important to you know to keep them in check and I'm like that's what emotional intelligence is about
So why would you anyway so it's not being ruled by your emotions?
Emotional intelligence is the ability to understand and manage emotions
Which I'm using the word emotion in it, so it's not a great definition. So to go give more specifics
these are some of the examples of
aspects of emotional intelligence
self-awareness
confidence empathy achievement collaboration motivation resilience conflict management
Ton of other things, but those that's the kind of them genre they're talking about
You may know them by the term soft skills
this is the term that I hate and I very rarely use the word hate because I think it adds a lot of negativity the
World, but I'm using it here because I feel that's dispassionately about it. I hate the word soft skills. What?
Because one softness it's has become associated with weakness in our culture
So we say things like he's gone soft to me and you know, he's gotten weak or something like that
I also think it's weirdly associated just with women. So in the early 90s, there were these commercials
Come see the softer side of Sears and it was when Sears introduced in addition to the hardware that they were selling
Accessories and clothing for women and it's not that soft skills being associated with women is bad because women are bad
but rather because it's a limited view and I think soft skills quote our
Emotional intelligence really is for everyone. Not just women not just people you know who identify with their femininity. It's really for everyone
to illustrate this I had I this example was gifted to me by the universe because when I was on my way to another
Conference where I was getting this talk, I stepped onto an airport shuttle and they were talking about the Super Bowl
and they were talking about Doug Peterson who I guess is the coach of the Eagles and since they wanna cut this slide in if
They have lost he was taking it out, but they said Doug Peterson really has emotional intelligence
He recognized that word but that turnaround is so excited
he recognizes that football is not just a tactical game but a psychological game and
I was just like yes, if emotional intelligence is associated football then how can we possibly call it a soft skill so soft skill so
Please stop calling them soft skills, please. Please, please
Please also call the people skills because people skills has become
The punchline of jokes. So this is from the movie office space and the people who have come to do layoffs
Ask him ask this guy what his job is I just got a bit of Dom
So they asked me what he does and he mentions that he
takes
requirements from the customer and takes them to the engineers and he it says maybe they acts like confused and I have people skills and
So it's you know people skills. It's easy to make fun of because it's become kind of cliched coentrão
So instead I recommend that we use this term catalytic skills
Now this comes from a talk that I saw by Daniel Goleman
He was getting a talk at Google and you can watch it on YouTube this link
And he says he calls them catalytic skills because they help us
Catalyzed our technical skills meaning to help us acquire new technical skills and apply them more effectively
So so I think I would love it. If we ditch the term Sox Bill Vol together call them catalytic skills
Ok
So why should you care about any of this?
So let's talk about why software projects fail. So this data this is a subset of reasons that
Project software projects fail they the application developer developer's Alliance surveyed
850 software developers smoked each group, but
Whatever somewhere to start from and here's some of the reasons that they gave so the ones in blue
You'll see changing or poorly documented requirements poor team organizational management developer churn or loss of key talent. These are all
things that would benefit from
emotional intelligence the way on the end
Not insignificant, but less than the others you have immature dev tools and application platforms
but I feel like a lot of the discourse in tech is around how to optimize the dev tools and application platforms and
Really? That's not not my software projects are failing. I mean some of them are that's one reason but
Largely, it's it's more on the human side that our projects are failing
And you can read more and that's very clear
Another study so they the in 1994 but it's still highly relevant. You still haven't fixed it
There's this paper that came out the essential competencies of software engineers, and there's very tiny table that's not important to you
All right now, but you can access the paper there. And again, I'm gonna put these slides up
But the top three how much of the tea is the palest that are that
Exceptional software engineers are team oriented they seek help and they help others Wow. Okay, so that those are all aspects of emotional intelligence
Another reason you should care. So it seems like every week there's a new article about burnout in tech
I've also written one which is accessible there. And I think that's because
burnout really happens when we're not able to control our
Responses to situations and when we feel a kind of powerless and emotional intelligence can really help with that
So I know we like to think I certainly used to think that I came to work and I shut off my emotions
I'm completely rational completely logical. You know, I'm just debating issues using you know, pure reason and
It's just not true
So I hate to break it to you. You're not a robot. You're not none of you
You're human being and every single human being has emotions
every single one
Apple CEO Tim Cook in a commencement address last year said I'm not worried about artificial intelligence
Giving computers the ability to think like humans. I'm more concerned about people thinking like computers
So even if we could think like robots it wouldn't be a good idea
Because we're humans and we need to to care about each other
So as a software engineer here are some of the things that you do on a daily basis
potentially that could benefit from emotional intelligence if you think effective feedback and code reviews naming variables is
Really benefits from empathy designing api's also benefits from empathy which is an aspect of emotional intelligence
Negotiating with designers or product managers rallying support for a new tool quick story there
I was at a company and we were using a remote
conferencing tool called sakoku
And the quality was really bad and it was just it was always crashing because of how big our team was
So some of us that suggested we use zoom and we did this we prepared this very logical document
spreadsheet comparing the pros and cons and we you know trying to rally support and
Everyone was so emotional about it and it turned out that it wasn't because of the pros and cons, you know
They weren't convincing because the people who like to poco so much felt that it helped them feel more a lot. They
contributed to their sense of belonging on the team because it had this like these little
Office pictures of little offices like a virtual office and for some reason they had they had grown
Emotionally attached to this tool and so their response was so emotional because of that so it was hard
So we need to elevate the conversation from just a purely rational level to really address it on a human level
So even rallying support for a new tool a new framework in benefit from emotional intelligence
Also being able to motivate yourself to learn new skills
interviewing candidates
Definitely a big one here to be able to put people at ease into not rule out people unfairly
Through your interview style and also to mentor new hires. I
Would also suggest that the agile manifesto is a way of layering emotional intelligence on to software development
So I went through all of the principles of the agile manifesto and called out which elements of emotional intelligence each one addresses
So here's just one example
So one of the principles is we both know changing requirements even late in development
Agile processes harness change for the customers competitive advantage in this because the empathy service service orientation
adaptability
Optimism and initiative which are all aspects little intelligence
so Jerry Weinberg wrote this great book the psychology of computer programming in the early 70s and
He said it is possible to be too smart for programming if the person is not smart enough to use this intelligence
To modify the social behavior and methods of conversation
I thought it is a nice quote and it was the 70s which is why it uses his but I
Want it to the percentage of with fidelity's there? Ok?
There are also some personal benefits many personal benefits to growing emotional intelligence. It helps reduce your stress improves productivity
helps you with better relationships
Increases your happiness and I know a citation needed
so we've visit the greater good science center at UC Berkeley's website because they have tons of
Research backs studies on this so that's why I have new citation for each one
You can do your research take my word for it, or you can decide I've decided that I don't necessarily need
Absolute proof of something working before I'm willing to experiment it if it has, you know a low investment
So I've also seen these in my own life
Okay, so assuming now that you're at least somewhat interested developing your emotional intelligence. Let's talk about how to do it
So I like to use a metaphor. That's not unfamiliar to people intent
So hopefully most of you are familiar with the idea of being on call I saw so we're the past day
There's been like a lot of discussion on Twitter. People are debating on call
I haven't really been following it, but they're apparently, you know, most people understand this idea of being on call
But just to make it clear
So if you if your site goes down or if there's something there's some kind of problem on your app or your website
somebody will get a notification probably not on an actual device like this anymore, but
that's you know, you're on call so
Being a human it's kind of like being on call all the time and you're distressing emotions are like alerts and similar
similarly to how
When you don't deal with an alert properly
on your system
It's similar to when you do that as a human
Disaster strikes. So what does it look like if you don't handle your remote channel alerts properly?
well, Daniel Goldman says out of control emotions can make smart people stupid and
What he means by that are some examples you might if you're over if you're very emotional about something
What you might do is send an email that you later regret I may or may not have done this in the past
You may send a slack message. That isn't particularly kind you may you know, yell at somebody and say something that you regret
You also just may be so distracted by how angry you are that you're not productive
It's like so this is why it's helpful to be able to manage your distressing emotions
And this is just one aspect of emotional intelligence, but I feel like it illustrates the bigger picture here
So that's the one we're gonna focus on
So I'd like to present to you an emotional incident runbook so similar to how when there's an alert on your system
Sometimes you'll have some kind of runbook you might call it a playbook and it's a list of things that you can do to help
troubleshoot the site
so maybe it's you know where to look in the logs to see if something's broken or
You know who to contact about this near that or what to look for in the database or whatever. It may be to troubleshoot
so I'm gonna do that but for your emotional incidents
So here's the process I'd like to present
Which is slowing down
Tending to your needs
Offering empathy and proceeding calmly these are steps. You can take whenever you find yourself in the middle of an emotional incident
The spells out stop which is nice
Easy to remember so we'll go through each one in turn
The first one is slow down
Which is a bit ironic. It's I'm a fast talker and I'm saying slow down, but it's very important
so I took a meditation class a few years ago and
The instructor was talking about how our anxious mind is kind of like a jar of water
That's full of sediment that's been shaken up and all of our anxious thoughts are like the sediment and that
Meditation or just slowing down in an informal way?
Allows the sediment or the anxious thoughts to settle so that we have clarity
in the jar meaning you can see through the water but also
Metaphorically in your mind you have more clarity about your situation. That's why it's so important
True story. I dropped that meditation class after the laughs
I thought it was moving too slowly and I thought I'd be remiss and get it faster
So I had a lot to learn but I think I've made some progress since then
So the next I was tending to your needs
So what are beads what I'm even in Venice?
So here are some examples of needs they come from a book called nonviolent communication by Marshall Rosenberg highly recommend this book
So we have basic means like shelter arrest food safety
We also have me it's like autonomy creativity meaning love respect trust closeness community fun
Laughter beauty order. Peace
So most time you have spiritual needs
These are examples of needs that meet we could be experiencing and they definitely affect our emotional responses
So the empathy piece is trying to understand what the other person is feeling
Valuing and eating so you slow down
You understand your needs you tend to them?
If you can first you understand what the other person is feeling and then you proceed calmly
With what you've decided based on all that information
so I'd like to walk through an example just because that really helped and
This may be difficult to read so I'm going to read it out
It's actually difficult for me to read on here so quick. You look closer
But yeah, so here's an example of an exchange between two developers and please imagine them as whatever gender you would like
I tried to use names that are commonly used for multiple genders. So
the first one says
Alex I saw that you set the points on a story by yourself again, we're supposed to vote as a team now
They're discussing an issue tracker where you set points on a story like in them an agile software development
The other developer says I never agreed to that the story was just a quick task. What does it matter?
We have a process in place and we're supposed to stick to it. You always do that bring up process
We waste so much time talking about process
I just want to get things done and you're always being reckless and breaking things
We have processes in place for a reason if you can't stick to them. Maybe you shouldn't be on the team
Yeah, maybe I shouldn't well, okay that escalated quickly. So this is what happens when we don't apply emotional intelligence
we think we're having a perfectly rational rational debate about process and this and that but you can tell people's emotions are definitely
Involved here, even if what they're saying
You know may just be could be potentially just raffle
so
Let's walk through the steps to slow down. So the first is you know
just because you see something that bothered to you don't just immediately jump in and try to
Criticize someone or tell them why they're wrong, right? So let's take a step back and try to unwind this a bit. Ok, so
Morgan sees that Alex have set the story point without consulting the team
Okay. So what is it likely that Morgan values in this situation? I would say that Morgan values order
Organization structure process. Why does this person value these things? Well, I would imagine it's because
Morgan would like santaville deliver value to the customers in organized and productive efficient way, so
What is Alex value in this situation? It seems to me like
Alex values moving quickly
not getting weighed down by excessive process and
Why would Alex value that well?
probably because Alex would like to deliver value to the customer efficiently and productively so
Really if you take the time to slow down you realize hey
We're both on the same team and probably our end goal is actually the same. So, although we may have some different values in between
We don't need to have this really hostile exchange
Okay, so slow down
Looked at the needs. So let's proceed calmly. So let's see how this conversation could go
So Morgan instead says Alex when I saw that you set the points on a story without consulting anyone
I felt concerned because I need to trust that we share responsibility as the team. Can you explain what happened?
Alex, says the story was just a quick one point task. What does it matter?
Morgan says, it seems like you value moving quickly and feel that process sometimes gets in the way is that right now?
It says well, yeah, I don't want to talk about process. I just want to get things done
Morgan says I also want to get things done. It's also important to me that I feel a sense of order
Would you be willing to send a quick note to the team when you point a story on your own so that we at least?
We know and then Alex says yeah, I guess I can do that
So you'll see this example if I didn't create a magical world where both?
People are applying these techniques in this situation. Pretty much only Morgan is applying new techniques, but it can still work
so
You know and you can reach a solution where because you remember what the end goal is
You can come to something that both people can agree with
So I know
If you're like me when I was sort of talking about this what a waste of time to have to do this in every conversation
Well one you don't have to do it in every conversation because sometimes you build up rapport with people so that you don't need to
You're unlikely to have
an emotional incident every single time
But when you do feel yourself getting emotional like when you feel your heart starting to beat faster your fight-or-flight
Mechanisms are kicking in. That's really when you know that you need to slow down and work through these steps
so giving you kind of a starter guide to this emotional incident runbook, but like I said,
It's a much bigger picture here with emotional intelligence and you'll start to notice patterns the things that you value so much that trigger you
And trigger that emotional response. So for example some people value
fairness, right
So if something at work happens that seems unfair which is one of the most common complaints in the workplace
Then you may feel yourself getting emotional
So it's really about just being able to communicate those needs in a productive way and it really takes practice a lot of practice
I can tell you somebody who's had to make this transition
But it's so worth it and the whole time. I think it's important to keep in mind a growth mindset
Which means let's not say I'm not a people person or I'm an introvert or I'm an engineer. I'm not a manager
So why do I have to care about people but instead they hey these skills can help me be more effective in my job
So I'm gonna work to develop them over time and I'm gonna be patient with myself as I'm learning this
so to this point I
Would like to at least do a little bit of exercise a little exercise with you to give you an example with this
Don't worry. No one's gonna have to say anything and we're talked to
It's all gonna happen in here so think about a time when you lost control of your emotions
So when you yelled at somebody or you wrote name read email we all we all do it
You know at least in your head really have gotten angry at somebody I guarantee it
It's not again. You can tackle me at the end of office
Okay
so think of an incident and if you're having trouble recalling
Something I would say an easy one is getting stuck in traffic
Everyone gets so annoyed in traffic right? Because someone cuts you off or someone's not going fast enough. Someone's doing something differently
so
just I'm gonna pause for a few seconds and just let you think and try to try to come call to mind an incident and
Again, you're not gonna have to tell anyone about this though. It doesn't matter
It's about work personal life, whatever but think about a time when you feel that maybe you said something you regret
You did something a little bit on
That was clearly motivated by out of control emotions. Okay. So let's take it a few seconds
So hopefully you have one in mind dot you can use the the car one because
that would probably works and if you don't drive you could think about
When you've had to wait in a really long line
Perhaps at the DMV or somewhere else
you couldn't get the DMV if you don't even if you don't drive I guess but or
Like maybe in line at a amusement park or something? Okay. So then keeping in mind that instead they thought of
What would have happened if maybe you'd slowed down?
Okay, think about what were your needs in that moment? So let's see in the traffic example, so when I'm stuck in traffic and I
actually get more upset when somebody's like tailgating me because I just i've
Been rear-ended before and so I kind of have this fear around that so when somebody is tailgating me
What I feel is fear. I feel fear
I feel
annoyance because I'm like don't they know that there's certain following distance that we learned when we took into a driver's test and we're supposed
To be following that and I actually drive quickly. So it's surprising to me even in when it happens. But anyway
So that's what I'm valuing. So then you know, I could just say oh what a jerk, right
But that's what we're gonna do here. So we're gonna think okay offer empathy. Why is this person tailgating me?
What are they feeling value me in needing? Well, I suspect that they are trying to get somewhere quickly
Maybe they're in a rush because of something, you know distressing happening in their life
Maybe it's just trying to get home to see their family for some reason. They're in a hurry
Maybe they have a bad day and they feel powerless and this is you know tailgating me
It's how they're trying to assert their dominance
I don't know what it is, but I can I can think about these possibilities to help build empathy. I can proceed calmly
So what are my options?
Yeah, I could just like slam drinks
Right, but I try to avoid that I do sometimes tap but not in an annoying way like more and just like, you know
I'm scared way, but but again, I can't control how its how its interpreted, but maybe I can change lanes
maybe I could get off I could actually get off they at the highway take an exit and then maybe you know try again and
Hope for the best there are things I could do but what I'm not gonna do is get angry
And I'm not going to you know, try to get behind them and then Hoggart or you know, flash my brides or something
I'm gonna do something calmly. So in your situation see you. You know, what were you meeting?
No, what were you meeting?
And what was the other person needing and if no one else was involved?
You can just focus more on what you were needing or what
You know how you were reacting to yours to your situation?
So again, let's take it to you second three using like I use that example. That's to try to help but
Since I was talking about full time, it would've been hard for you to do both parts
so I'm gonna pause again kind of think about what you were needing in that distressing moment that you thought of and
What anyone else involved in that situation was meeting?
So again
You don't have to share you can just think think of that and I would try to do that
on a daily basis and again it takes time because there's so much to Annoying stuff that happens in life there gonna be people who
Have totally different values from you that do really things that just really irritate you because of your values
so, you know just try to remember on daily basis to try its member to stop and
implement these steps
the last time I get this talk I
Step three was empathize. So it's spelled step and I realized that didn't really make sense
And I was like wait a second. I have to change it to offer empathy and stops
I'm pretty happy with this kind of thing. Okay. So yes emotional intelligence helps you become more effective as an individual
Yes, it can help build more effective teams, but I think there's a bigger picture here. I
Think the problems were facing intact all relate to this lack of concern for human beings and by problems were facing in tech
I mean, yeah, it's the lack of inclusion and diversity. Yes. The fact that there's a lot of unethical choices made in tech
Yes
the fact that we're building products that can be addictive and that can be hurtful to
Society and I think all of that relates to a lack of concern for human beings so that I think that's the bigger picture here
you
Karen Armstrong says it all she writes if it is not tempered by compassion and empathy
reason can lead men and women into a moral void and I would say that's what happened in tech right now because we've been so
Obsessed with just a technical side to logic. The reason we really love compassion and empathy go by the wayside and because of that
We've really created a moral void in tech
So this is a meditation garden that's near me where I live in Encinitas and I liked I didn't take this picture because I thought
It would be like not cool to break out my phone at a meditation. Pardon. So I got this one your website
but I go there and it's a beautiful view of the ocean and they have this little booklet and I read this quote and it
Really spoke to me if I want to share it with you
when people speak of political social or international problems
They often do not realize that these conditions are nothing more than the accumulated thoughts and actions of millions of individuals
And the only way to change world conditions is to change ourselves
So I really think the even bigger picture is this is not just about tech applying these skills of emotional intelligence
Can be so important it can be so powerful to create a more peaceful world
Where we actually care enough about each other to understand where from and we could make a really big difference here. So
With that. Thank you very much. I did take this picture awesome movies
This one I can take credit for here's my newsletters that compassionate coding comm. It's also my website blog posts stuff like that
I'm going to be having a course on
How to avoid burnout and tag coming out soon. So please sign up if you're interested in any of that
We're just getting free resources or staying in touch for whatever. Thank you very much